hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well and nicker McKean
ethics book 8 in the course of
discussing this this broad topic of
friendship one of the issues that
Aristotle is going to talk about is the
relationships within what we can call me
the household the Waco's in in Greek the
and this encompasses more than just the
nuclear family although what we nowadays
call the nuclear family is really the
Coromant it encompasses everything
involved with being a land owner a house
holder somebody who has probably
servants as well who has the resources
that means to be able to engage in
commerce with other people to engage in
social life all that is part of the
household and here are some things that
some sort of friendship ought to be
working within the household we're going
to talk about the role of affection in
that in a separate video here we want to
look at is the relationship that
whatever soul sees is essentially a
structural similarity between what goes
on in the household in the relations
between the people and what he calls
political regimes pull a bullet AI these
are also sometimes
as constitutions these are wrong ways in
which we can classify societies
political communities they're derived
from some of the categories that
Aristotle works out and some of his
other books like the politics so I'm not
going to spend an awful lot of time
discussing this this side just for its
own safe we can do that some other time
when we're discussing the politics
proper but it is important to know a few
things about Aristotle's conception of
political regimes you notice that we've
got six of them up here and they can be
arranged in pairs that are actually
opposites to each other and there's
greater opposition Aristotle says with
these are the top of the list monarchy
is very very different than than tyranny
although it does have one thing in
common
quite literally one thing in common
one ruler democracy and democracy are a
little bit closer together and
aristocracy and oligarchy are sort of a
middle state there they're further apart
that are these two but they're not quite
so far apart as are these two so let's
talk about what each of these mean the
other one in which we can understand
this is you know instead of the
opposition's sort of this axis and as
we're going from the higher to the lower
in this case we're going from one person
being in charge one person determining
one person ruling down to the many not
not everybody but at least the many
those who are citizens aren't able to
engage in ruling perhaps not all at the
same time so monarchy Aristotle says is
when one person rules but it's not
enough for one person to rule because
that's also the case in tyranny
what differentiates them would separate
this side apart from this side is who is
the rule exercised for is it carried out
primarily just for the people on this
side the people in charge or is it
something that is being done for the
good of other people in the community
indeed out of the community
as a whole so a real monarchy can only
be in a monarchy in Aristotle's view
when power is being exercised not to
retain power for the monarch not to get
everything you know for the monarchy and
his cronies or household or anything
like that but for the entire community
if you stop doing that you cease being a
monarch and you thereby become the worst
of all things which is to be a tyrant a
tyranny is a purse T remaining is almost
a person it's a person corrupting the
entire political regime or establishment
or Constitution and making everything
turn on his or her will only for his or
her benefit or for the benefit of those
who he is he or she is closely connected
it could also be for you know their
class their party their their race their
whatever we want to pick some sort of
division but the key thing is one person
is in charge when we talk about
dictatorships dictatorships are
typically tyrannous if they're what we
call an enlightened despotism and the
person really really is working pretty
good everyone else which quite often is
not the case then that would be a
monarchy right now if we if we expand
the the number of rulers a bit more
widely and we have something like a
class system perhaps then we have an
aristocracy only when the people who are
in charge are in fact the onerous
toastie the best the people who have
virtue and who are running the community
and ruling it for the benefit of the
other members of the community not
merely themselves so it's not enough
just to possess virtue you also have to
be exercising it and Aristotle says that
when that's not what's happening when
you have a few people ruling not not
just one person but you know the ruling
class or perhaps
in our own time you might talk about a
political class right then you have an
oligarchy which literally means rule by
the few typically these are going to be
the rich or the powerful who will often
coincide because we have power you can
quite often work the system to make some
money out of it if you have money you
can usually work that to you know get
something out of it to get some power
and all the darks are not interested in
the good of the community as such
they're interested in they're good
they're interested in perhaps the good
of those who benefit them but they're
not interested in in other members of
the community and so that does a problem
that these are what we call corrupted
regimes as opposed to good at regimes to
monarch ricean democracy now we tend to
think of democracy in the West as being
a good thing can't be democratic enough
Aristotle doesn't see democracy in
itself is a good thing he wants to
qualify that if we're just talking about
mob rule that actually often turns back
into a tyranny that's not a good thing
American Idol not an example of a great
way to run on a society right popular
vote can be quite good if the people are
actually well-informed if there are
certain limits in place and that is much
more like what he calls a timocracy in a
timocracy it's not anything goes so long
as the people decide again the
difference between them is going to be
in a democracy the rulers are many but
the many are deciding on the basis of
what's good for the entire community not
just themselves
now just their own class whether it be
the middle class the lower class you
know not just their own group not just
even perhaps their own country if we
want to think about this in a light way
Oh Aristotle doesn't doesn't really
concern himself with that in a democracy
the people who are in charge are doing
it for their group and this is why we
often get party politics and
involved in democracies that shouldn't
be the case quite so much in a democracy
so we have now these these six different
regimes right how does that play out in
terms of the family
well Aristotle tells us quite a bit
about this there's a father-son
relationship I think in our own time we
might say parent sibling you realize
that Aristotle is of course rather
sexist in some of the things that he's
saying here particularly about husbands
and wife but you know just trying to see
to see past that to what we're getting
at here he talks about the relationship
between husband and wife spousal
relations and then he talks about the
relationships between siblings he talks
in terms of brothers I don't see any
reason why we couldn't expand this to
talk about other siblings as well and
you notice that each one of them
corresponds to one of the good regimes
which means that one you know there
there's a principle of rulership who was
actually in charge yeah how is power
exercised and for whose benefit is it
being exercised so let's take a look at
what he actually says about these he
says we can find in likenesses that is
homo homo motto right they had
similarities and models Potidaea cotta
in the household to the these regimes
and he says the relationship of father
to sons is monarchy Co monarchical regal
the father is essentially like a king
father's first care is for his
children's welfare that's a good father
right and he says this is why people
call Zeus the the father for the ideal
of kingship is paternal government that
Aristotle makes a contrast that he says
not everybody's like that here is what
we might think about you know how this
would apply to our own time if it's
possible for a parent to be a monarch in
respect to their children that's only
the case when the parent is
actually doing things for the benefit of
the children may not be recognized by
the children as such but the monarch in
order to be a monarch actually has to be
a good person and has to be exercising
power for the benefit of the entire
household if they're not doing that then
they are actually a tyrant and then
remember that is the worst of regimes
Aristotle is by implication saying
parents who exercise too radical power
over their children are the worst people
in the household and they make the
household into the worst kind of regime
who does he talk about he says the
Persians among the Persians paternal
rule is tyrannical for the Persians use
their sons as slaves this is a
fundamental problem the Aristotle of
course you know doesn't criticize the
the institution of slavery in any
comprehensive way he says that in many
cases slavery is unjust and you know the
wrong people are slaves when the wrong
people are masters but it does feel that
some possibility for you know some power
relations that are of a despotic the
slave to the master kind of kind of
weight that is inappropriate within the
household for the relationship between
parents and children really parents and
anybody parents you know the two parents
together should not be despotic brothers
and with with brothers should not be
despotic Aristotle doesn't worry about
whether you know what about the servants
should it be despotic in relation to
them but we could in fact discuss this
further and extend but we're not going
to do that here what about a husband and
wife spouses he says the relationship of
husband and wife seems to be in the
nature of an aristocracy the husband
rules in virtue of fitness being fit to
rule and so in matters that belong to
man's sphere manners suited to a woman
he hands over to his wife now you've
gotta read a little bit in between the
lines because when it comes to the
household what does that actually mean
the wife in Athenian society actually
runs most of the household the mainland
doesn't do that much the woman may
actually the one who's in charge governs
much of it but he is ultimately in
charge so he's delegating you could say
and this is Aristotle's sort of
idealized view of gender relations like
I simply might want to you know bear
this in mind and criticize it could be
the case though that in some
partnerships that we currently have
today that might actually be a good
thing one partner handles the long-term
finances the other person handles the
day-to-day budgeting right there are all
sorts of splits like that now what does
a result say about how this can go wrong
he says when the husband controls
everything he transforms the
relationship into an oligarchy for a
governance in violation of fitness not
in virtue of superiority the idea behind
an aristocracy is that people should do
what it is that they're best suited to
and then the other person should listen
to them but they should do it in such a
way as it's for the benefit of everybody
involved so if one person is better with
handling the kids and discipline and the
constants you know not a sense that goes
along with children whether it be the
husband or the wife that person want to
be in charge of it when one person
irrigates to themselves everything that
says I'm the one who's in charge
Aristotle says that's a corruption of
this that that's a problem within the
household I'm going out a little bit
further he talks about brothers and he
says though there's one other thing that
he talks about sometimes when the wife
is an heiress it's is she who rules in
this case Authority goes not by virtue
but by wealth and power as an oligarchy
so
again we might extend that to thinking
in terms of both parties there's an old
expression when you marry money you earn
it so when you're marrying into an
unequal relationship power might be
exercised in that way going back to the
brothers so brothers he says they want
to be in a sort of democracy they are
equals but they're not completely equals
insofar as a different image there's a
little bit of inequality there so he
says if the difference in age be great
the friendship between them cannot be of
the fraternal type then he says where
did we see democracy democracy appears
most fully in households without a
master without anybody in charge for in
them all the members are equal but it
also prevails where the ruler of the
house is weak and everyone is allowed to
do what he likes and you know that
doesn't sound so bad
right but if you think about what's
required to hold a houseful together
think about we're going to worry about
money at this point
just think about scheduling all the
different activities together you know
husband wife kids you know the dog and
you know who knows what else Mayberry's
and all scheduling who decides when
things are going to happen who settles
scheduling conflicts does everybody just
throw whatever they want onto the
calendar and say me me me me me well
that would be an example of democracy
the the many rule the many get a lot of
freedom but it doesn't turn out that
well for everybody
and it tends to you know give way
eventually to somebody saying that's it
I'm laying down the law right now I'm
gonna be the tyrant so why is all this
important in terms of friendship
Aristotle says that both in the
political community and in the household
friendship has a alignment let's call it
with justice and all of this is a matter
of justice what's right and what's wrong
who always what to who should be
exercising power for what reason to what
extent same thing applies over here so
Aristotle thinks that it can be helpful
to look at these political regimes to
understand how things ought to be
working and where things go wrong within
the household or as we call it these
days the family